Kelly Marie Tran I was so thrilled to
hear your name calls and see you walk
out there I mean we have to talk about
that moment I mean the reaction from the
crowd was just insane what was that like
for you I cried I mean I was very
unprepared for that moment and very
overwhelmed immediately and tried to
like shield my face from the fact that I
was like oh I don't know to do with this
but it was so there's so much love here
for something that we all get to be a
part of and you know it's like the last
one and it's really really special and I
just feel really really grateful to be
here and I'm trying to just be really
present in every moment so that was I
just feel so much love I mean I gotta
ask because I don't know if there's
anything you want to clear the air about
about after what happened after the last
Jedi you know I know there was some
backlash I mean that moment for me just
felt like such a healing moment being in
that audience did I feel like that for
you I think it absolutely did I think
that it also is not just for like that I
think it's more the whole franchise I
know it's like everyone's so emotional
because we're wrapping up this amazing
thing and I cannot believe that I still
get to be here and be a part of that and
I think that we're all sort of feeling a
lot of emotions because of that yeah so
yeah last question there is there was a
photo of you and Ray together I got it
yeah what can you tease about girls
talking in a film what yeah but what can
you tease about their dynamic um I don't
know how much I can say cuz JJ's like
the refeed away from that I will say
that I'm really excited for everyone to
sort of see these characters back in
action and to see the way with their
relationships I've grown it's gonna be
really exciting
[Applause]
[Music]